your head came off
hhhh pan these things are awesome really
if you think about it that shotgun is
like our taller the kids this shotgun
shoots bullets that are like as big as a
car is probably about the size of a I
don't know sit down or something like
that
it's huge welcome to folding ideas
season 3 episode 2.1 last time on
folding ideas we talked about the end of
evangelion
and particularly focusing a lot on
Shinji and chin G's role within the
narrative and also the whole meta story
surrounding of it surrounding the whole
meta story surrounding it about whether
or not uh what's his name whether or not
Anna was trolling his fan base by by
making it that way and a lot of people
sort of mentioned like hey you missed
this you missed that and the one note
that I do want to make actually on that
front is afterwards I was talking with
some people and particularly I was
watching like once I was done I started
watching a lot of the other reviews that
people have done I will say that I
started to get I don't know if you'd
call it Stockholm Syndrome but at this
point I actually think like barring
certain parts of it and certain themes
we think are really clunky like a lot of
Enda beta is actually just like this
absolutely brilliant sort of postmodern
a postmodern movie about the end of the
world one of the things that I noticed
in watching these other things was a a
cultural or in an interpretive
difference that you could come up with
depending on which version of the show
you had seen that there were these
differences in the Dubs
and the interpretation that I got out of
the movie depending on which dub I was
watching so I watched it and I made all
of my notes and I edited from the
original Japanese voiceover work
the English voice dub in particular is a
lot more sympathetic
towards Shinji um much more pathetic he
really really really sounds like a child
lost in the supermarket because of the
way that the dialogue is presented
Aska comes across as much more abusive
she's still a pretty hard edged
character either way why shouldn't he
behave such in such a way given how much
of a bit Jascha is to him it's a little
bit more understandable when in the
english dub she does come across as a
lot more aggressive and abusive in a way
that's that seems unjustified whereas in
the japanese dub his voice work
particularly during his breakdown the
instrumentality switchover in the
japanese it is it's not just angry or
scared it's it's spiteful it is he is
yelling these things with the intent of
causing hurt and you hear that in the
Japanese but you don't necessarily get
that in the English so that was one of
the things that I noticed right away
that could they could certainly have an
impact on the way that people interpret
this a lot of the others things that
came out and people made some very very
very good points and I couldn't I was
honestly overwhelmed with the the
feedback and I wasn't able to respond to
everyone but I did read more or less
everything that I saw and I really
enjoyed the conversations that people
started having having about this I was
expecting honestly a little bit more
backlash but a lot of people really
really seemed to resonate with with this
idea and in particular the idea of
shinji sort of as a um nice guy I don't
get why women don't want to hang out
with me I'm a nice guy I saw that when I
was watching through but I couldn't I
couldn't script it in in a satisfactory
way so I just kind of put in
as much of his dialogue as possible I
just put in as much of the dialogue as
possible and hope that other people
would pick up on it a number of people
did now there is one more thing
one more thing that I want to dedicate
some some time to and I didn't really
manage to cover all of the possibilities
and so I'm going to cover something that
will just call consideration for
consideration for is that the two
endings of Evangelion the broadcast
ending and the movie are not necessarily
mutually exclusive now there are a
number of fan theories that have cropped
up surrounding this and they go in sort
of a similar a similar vein here but by
and large I disregard most of them since
a lot of them are very I find them
apologetic in an unsatisfactory way
because most of them seem most of them
seem to be focused in particular on
trying to bring end of evangelion
and the finale of the show into the same
timeline a lot of them revolve around a
notion that what happens and then the
other or one happens at a specific point
within the other now before we go any
further with this I want to be
explicitly clear here that this is
largely talking about what happens to
shinji by and large and i would say this
about the entirety of end of evangelion
anything that involves the secondary
characters um anyone in in nerve
headquarters I would say that 100% that
is exactly what they had planned to
happen in to happen in the the ending of
the show anyway like in terms of seal or
say light and even the part like you
know people melting into tang I think
that was that was planned from from the
get-go that was what they wanted to have
happen
so in consideration for that the two
endings are not are essentially
divergent they are the two possible
outcomes of a single divergent like
reality altering event and I believe
that towards the end of the show they
started playing with this idea of
duality and you do see a lot of this
sense of duality like I can I can see a
lot of this duality coming out
particularly with people from a buddhist
shinto background interpreting christian
mythology they're going to see you know
that that good versus evil nature and
thus order like the duality of man is
kind of a big thing in christianity of
the you know it's like oh well with
fennel you know that man is at war with
his with his evil side no man has fallen
and that the the state that man needs to
attempt to reclaim is one of perfection
and one of unity so well it is not
perfectly mapped to that the real-life
belief system I think those themes
resonated with them in some way and they
started trying to insert them towards
the end and so I would propose that the
two endings both happen but they both
happen as parallel possibilities of a
single event and what I'm going to use
to back this up is actually a reference
to the newer the the rebuild of
evangelion which note I haven't watched
yet so this is me this is a bit of an
experiment I'm going to put this idea
out there and then I'm going to confirm
this idea and I'll report back later to
see if it actually pans out but one of
the things that's tipping me off towards
this is that in the naming of all of the
episodes or the the movies within
rebuild of evangelion there is that do
Ally that that contemporary duality in
the names of all of them so it's like
you will not pass they all have a they
all have a parenthetic disqualifier
inserted into the middle of their
statement so that the statement
as it exists on the paper is at the same
time both the affirmative version of
that of that statement and the opposite
of affirmative negative the the non
negative the negative version doesn't
happen doesn't happen the titles for all
of them you know are routed into that
kind of a duality as a theme and now I
want to see I haven't watched them yet
but I'm going to and I want to confirm
whether or not that theme carries
through into the actual movies
themselves in some way or another I
would expect it if it is there to be
quite subtle but I'm thinking that the
entire purpose of rebill is ultimately
to expand this idea of duality so that
it runs throughout the entire show that
the original show in the new show will
essentially sit in parallel to each
other as a dual exploration of the same
series of events coming to either
similar or disparate conclusions what
will ultimately confirm this will
unfortunately have to wait until like
2015 or so when the final movie in the
series actually comes out in Japan
because that's the one that will cover
the same it'll cover the same events as
end of evangelion and the end of the TV
show so we've got a few years left
before we can ultimately confirm whether
or not that's what they're doing but I
suspect that's what the I suspect that's
the way that they're going to go with it
because I see a lot of those themes just
sort of being inserted in very subtle
ways so what that would be that would
not be you know it's not in my mind it's
not that oh the reason the reason why I
find a lot of the fan theories really
sort of unsatisfying is that none of
them is clean in any way shape or form
in terry's like particularly when they
want to go with this whole thing about
it's like oh well this one happens and
this one happens during this other event
because by and large how they end up
being is that like
the end of the show either happens in
Shinji's mind kind of during the whole
like cluster II montage of things and
then he wakes up on the beach or it
happens in Shinji's mind after the
events on the beach why I find this
unsatisfying is that they are still
these these giant polar opposite events
and and I just don't find it in any way
remotely satisfying to think that okay
well shinji has this massive meltdown
that he has that meltdown and then goes
through a phase of self-acceptance and
realizing that he has control over the
over his own existence and then
immediately just slips into this slummy
funk
and the other version isn't much better
either because the other version would
be that that it's post instrumentality
so he chokes Aska on the beach and then
sits there and at some indeterminate
period in the future he just gets over
it the reason I find that the reason I
find that unsatisfactory is because
there is absolutely nothing that happens
in those final moments that leave any
sort of indicator that the circumstances
are going to change that events are
start in motion in fact quite the the
ending of the movie is explicitly static
it is extremely static it is not an
ending where things are in motion and
things are restarting it is a there's a
film theory that basically says that
characters are doing whatever you last
saw them doing until otherwise confirmed
I don't find it satisfying to to think
that it's like oh just he then just got
over it because to me to me they will
start at the same midpoint you know at
the beginning of those final episodes it
could go either way I find it a lot more
satisfying to believe that they're under
that they're exploring possibility and
exploring duality then I find then I
find it to try and reconcile them both
into a singular into a singular timeline
or singular event sequence end of
evangelion is starting to give me a
headache all right I think I'm done I'm
done with innovative and galleon for now
oh man I I didn't even get into like
Aska and the whole thing like I was
sitting on the bus like there's this one
moment like ask is pathos
just gets heartbreakingly sad both
because it's like it's so depressing but
it's also so sincere um in particular
when she's fighting all of the mass
production angels and she's got this
line you know that you can't hurt me
because I've got mama with me and it's
just oh oh so it's it's heartbreaking
it's just wow yeah so thank you like
with this end of evangelion episode
thank you so much for all of the like
great conversation great points that
have been brought up I think whether or
not you even like end of Ava it it gives
you something really interesting to talk
about and this is kind of why I tried to
focus on the the meta level of it anyway
is because that's almost like more
entertaining than the actual thing not
so tiny little tidbit
okay
ah
a lot of people say sale a um you know
they refer to it as sale a and I think
that's kind of how it's pronounced in
the show but keep in mind the the people
in the show the the voice actors the
original voice actors don't speak
English I'm pretty sure it's seal and
the only reason why I say that is
because of the apocalyptic references
you know that the the show is drawing on
all of this judeo-christian particularly
Christian mythology Book of Revelations
and all that and so by them being seal
and the members of seal the seals has a
lot more metaphoric resonance to it like
it makes more sense than just say lay
which is kind of this utterly nonsense
word so I believe that it's just a
Japanese transliteration of the word
seal